اخر صيحات النحافه ورشاقه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي عقار اوزيمبيك وهو في
الاساس دواء لعلاج داء السكري خصوصا مع
استخدام المشاهير تيك توك اكثر من 274
مليون مشاهده على فيسبوك حصل عليها
هاشتاين العقاري الطبي الذي اصبح الاكثر
شهره بين الباحثين عن نحافه جسمهم ونحته
بسرعه حيث يعدل علاج هذا احد الطرق التي
اصبحت شائعه لاجل التنحيف وانزال الوزن
ارتفع طلب على العقار الطبي خلال الاشهر
الماضيه بنسبه تصل الى سبعه وخمسين في
المئه في نهايه 2022 لكن الامر كان كارثيا
على مرضى السكري الذين اصبحوا يعانون من
نقص حاد في العلاج المنظم لسكر الدم في
جميع انحاء العالم ويعمل اوزنبك وهو الاسم
التجاري لدواء سيما جلوتايد من خلال
محاكاه هرمون ينظم الشهيه لخلق الشعور
بالامتلاء وهو الامر الذي يستهدفه
الباحثون عن جسم متناسق باسرع وقت ممكن
على فكره هو عباره عن ابره بتتاخد مره في
الشهر في البطن وهي دواء للسكر يعني ابره
سكري بالاساس طب هو مره بالاسبوع الدواء
تطويره تم تطويره لادويه السابقه من النوع
نفسه عرفت التجاريه باسم
وكمان فيكتوزا يعني هلا هو اوزنبك يعني
صار فيه كانه السر من اسرار هوليود
ولاحظنا كتير عالم فجاه تغير شكلهم اثر
هذه الابره واخرهم يعني صارت بني ادم ثاني
يعني بس لحتى نوضح انه هو دواء للسكري
وللاسف الكثير من المرضى لم يحصلوا عليه
بسبب طلب كبير عليه حول العالم بس سهام
انا سالت عنه اطباء يعني اول شغله مؤسف
انه ابر سكري ناس مرضى سكري يحتاجون هذه
الابر صارت مش موجوده في الصيدليات لانه
الناس صار الطلب عليها يعني زايد
على سبب مش محرز على اثنين وثلاثه كيلو
وبيقولوا لك هو عباره عن يعني زي ك
بخفف الشعور بالجوع عمله يعني ويا ريت
يصير مثل ما قلتي تسوعيه انه في ناس تموت
بسبب النقص الحاد في هذا الدواء وناس
تانيه تدور عليه عشان تجميل والتنحيف